hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the fide grand prix being
played in berlin uh it's the first game
of the rapids we skipped the second game
second game of the classical time format
as it was really a snoozefest i decided
maybe best to skip that would not really
a lot was happening here was a pretty
pretty
pretty quick italian game they didn't go
for the evans gambit so that was the
first disappointment and the second one
well it was just incredibly short so
yeah okay uh first one of the classical
was interesting second one not so much
so we skipped it and now the first game
of the rap it's uh it's a very
interesting one let's dive straight into
it so hikaru uh with the white pieces
opens with e4 we have e5 by levon knight
to f3 knight to c6 and bishop to b5
going for the rue lopez
the opening
we have a6 morpheus defense and now
bishop to a4 we have knight to f6
castles and bishop to a7 so these are
all top moves of the
of the line both of them no no it and
both of them have played it a a lot of
times so rook to e1 we have b5 now
chasing away the bishop bishop b3 and uh
here levon castles we have h3 taking
away the g4 square from black's pieces
bishop to b7 and now d3 and now uh black
strikes in the center with d5 with e
captures knight captures and now uh
hikaru can go for the e5 pawn but it's a
very very dangerous line knight captures
an e5 then the knight comes to d4 and
then
well yeah it's uh just a lot a lot of
pressure from black on on all sides
bishop is coming to d6 uh the knight
left the f3 squared the queen might have
access to h4 so some similar ideas like
in the marshall attack uh but uh maybe
maybe not as crazy but still hikaru
doesn't want to go into this he plays a4
uh sort of a uh
an anti-martial in a non-martial
situation uh we have knight to d for now
and the knight b to d2 so again this is
all very standard stuff nothing new here
knight captures some b3 knight captures
and knight to b4 now putting a lot of
pressure on white's uh
position
and now do you capture an e5 or not well
it's definitely the best move so here of
course he car will capture it now queen
to d5 putting pressure on g2 threatening
checkmate we have f3 defending against
checkmate and bishop to d6 now we have
d4 now adding another defender to the
knight uh and there is a known move uh
rook eight to d8 it was played in 2014
in gibraltar masters between eric hanson
and evgeny tomaszewski the game ended in
a draw but here uh levon plays rook 8 to
e8 and it is now as of move 16 that we
have a completely new game so a third
attacker on the knight
we have to defend it once again but
first a captures on b5 we have eight
captures and bishop to d2 now so putting
pressure on the knight if bishop at any
point captures an e5 then the bishop no
longer defends the knight so levon
quickly brings the knight back knight to
c6 and now bishop to f4 adding another
defender to the knight on e5 we have
king the h8 uh getting the king to a
little bit of a safer square
and bishop to h2 by hikaru sort of
giving black the move asking what you
play here and uh getting rid of the
knight from e5 is not an easy task
for example if you play f6 uh
which can be a good idea sometimes uh
here it's just not very good we're just
gonna trade everything knight captures
bishop captures with checking captures
bishop captures and now play something
uh and here we have this position where
and the material is equal
uh however uh hikaru would be up upon
and it's uh well it's a better end game
for for white if the rooks for example
get traded off uh the knight and queen
should be better than bishop and queen
these pawns are nicely placed in light
square so you're not going to be able to
do all that much with the light square
bishop so that's one thing so instead
levon just decides to trade everything
okay he has the black pieces he will try
better with white in the next game
knight captures an e5 d captures on e5
with bishop captures bishop captures
rook captures an e5 rook captures and
queen captures an e5 so now the material
is equal and he car plays queen to d4 he
offers a queen trade he wants to go into
the end game queen to g5 now with some
ideas of bishop captures on f3 as the g
pawn is pinned so queen to c5
offering another queen trade and
attacking the b5 pawn and lavon really
doesn't have a better option he has to
trade queens here so queen captures
knight captures attacking the bishop and
the bishop to d5 now you can't play
something like bishop to c8 because you
will lose the game if you try something
like this then rook here and if c6 then
rook here uh there's no way to uh to
defend the pawn so instead bishop to d5
later on you can play c6 if if black uh
uh it will have to defend the pawn so
rook to e7 uh we have c6 now the bishop
nicely defends the pawn and knight to d3
so it's very hard to imagine that
something could go wrong here
g6 and now rook to c7 so now you might
have some ideas of going after the pawns
with 95 you're going to put pressure
not there but for example on f7 and then
c6 and the knight and rook will be a
very nice team here so rook to a8 levon
is ready to go after these pawns so if
you try 95 now for example rook to a2 is
very strong so knight to b for first
attacking the bishop and the pawn twice
uh and here uh levon played king to g7
uh while maybe going after uh the
the the pawn here uh with rocato a1
check king somewhere now rook the c1
would have been a little bit more uh
you know true to the position as now if
the knight ever moves you first capture
the c2 pawn with check
but okay like i said it's a rapid game
so king to g7 and now he grabs the pawn
knight captures in c6 bishop captures
rook captures and now rook to d8
putting the rook to the center of the
board now you can go rook to d2 and
there you will control a lot of very
important squares
so here we have g4 by hikaru and again
this is one of the positions where b4
that's not a b for where b4 is again the
best move uh as it uh really doesn't
offer black much contra player for
example if black plays rook to d2 we can
play rook to c5 and it's uh it's a much
much better position for white so hikaru
try something similar although uh it
didn't really work out for him he first
played g4 uh now levon played rook to d2
and now he played h4 so now levon uh
pushed of course h5 we have g captures h
cap g captures on h5 and now b4 which is
similar but uh it's a problem because
now levon has rook to d4 with an attack
on both of these pawns so hikaru has to
give up one of them he played c3 of
course you guard the b for pawn now the
one just captures this pawn and now
again the material is equal
king to g2 we have rook to f4 king to g3
and now rook to f5 uh we have f4 uh now
comes h for with check you want to give
up this pawn for this pawn so levon
captures or rather hikaru captures the
long captures and now king to g5 we rook
to f3 putting pressure on this pawn so
if white goes for this pawn then black
captures this pawn so king g4 rook to d3
and now rook the c5 and it doesn't seem
like other player can make any sort of
progress here king of six we have king
to f4 king to e6 now comes king to e4
and now the thing is levon has to play
rook to g3 or rook to h3 but like i said
again this is rapid and rook and games
are the most complicated in games if you
don't know uh so much of it by heart you
will make a mistake at some point so
here levon plays a rook to d8 and this
now is a problem and hikaru could very
easily take advantage with
rook to e5 check this would force the
king because after rook to e5 check if
the king goes to the default you're just
going to deliver check trade rooks and
then the king and opponent game is
winning so you're gonna have to
play king back to f6 now rook captures
and now uh the the black king is uh on a
pretty terrible square the two connected
past pawns will be very strong but okay
hikaru tried something different he
played rook captures on b5 right away
which is pretty much the same only the
black king is a bit more active here
so rook to d1 now comes rook to b6 with
check king to d7 and now rook to f6 he
carl goes after the pawn uh also b5 b5
can be played but hikaru knows what he's
doing we have rook to f6 king to e7 and
now rook to f3 so the past pawns are
nicely defended and now uh hopefully
hikaru can start pushing them
king e6 we have rook to d3 offering a
rook trade and this is how you get your
king across uh the d file so here we
have f5 with check king d4 now comes
rook to b1 stopping the advancement of
the pawn because the b4 pawn falls so
rookie three check we have king to f6
now comes rook to e8 we have f4 by levon
and now uh rook to b8 you have to be
very careful if you go after the pawn
here then rook to e1 check and now levon
wins the game so instead after f4 we
have rook to b8 uh now preparing to
start advancing the c pawn but now king
to f5 we have b5 now we have f3 by lavon
now comes king to e3 going after the
pass pawn
and now rook to b3 and this is again
from a winning position for hikaru we
now go again into a position that's not
winning for hikaru so king to d3 we have
king to g4 and now king to c2 and
interestingly uh this position uh
is a draw but only if levon plays the
the absolute best move if not then hikar
wins the game so just for fun feel free
to pause the video what would you play
here with white uh sorry with black
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on
trying to save the rook and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show rook
the a3 is the only move that uh does not
lose the game for lavon uh idea being
that after king to b2 we're gonna play
rook a5 and now whatever white plays
let's say b6 we're gonna play rook to b5
check and okay we're still fighting the
the pawn is still in the game uh however
uh levon did not play this level played
f2 and it seems like uh you know it's
pretty good move you're gonna bring a
queen into the game the problem is uh
hikaru doesn't capture the rook if
hikaru did this then again it's a draw
uh but hikaru plays rook to f8 and now
look at this now the f2 pawn is hanging
but also uh the rook is hanging so you
should save your rook so here levon
played rook captures on b5 but now he
carplays rook captures an f2 and all of
a sudden uh levon realizes the horror of
the situation that his king is
completely cut off the f file and the
king will not be a part of this game
anymore so white has a very simple task
of just bringing the king up the board
and pushing the pawn at some point the
pawn will reach the queening square the
white king will be here black will have
to give up the rook for the pawn
or rather for the newly promoted queen
the the king will capture the rook and
then it's a simple king and rook against
king and of course levon knows this and
he was in this position on move 61 that
levon arunian resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here so
really really
tough uh tough break for levon who was
unbeaten in berlin up until this game
this is the first game that he lost so
he did not lose a single game in
classical but now in rapid you can see
how tricky it can be especially against
a speed demon like hikaru
but yeah those are rooken games super
complicated anyone can make a mistake
and here uh hikaru was was just better
so yeah that's the game i hope you guys
enjoy it enjoyed it always study the end
game as you can never study enough of it
i would like to wish a very happy
birthday to paul worthington and i would
like to thank uh francis air the emoji
pillow on my couch adult and lucifer 45
non-commercial ep for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon most
likely with game two of the match to see
if levon will bounce back or will he
carl be the winner of the first leg of
the feeder grand prix uh so thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day